[Music]
mando I've spoken this is the way quotes
references if you haven't seen Hara
mandalorian TV reactions you guys
they're all up on YouTube so look out
for that playlist there's probably a
card popping up on this video at some
point major news in the television world
today we need some good news ah and
today brings us some awesome ones
rosario Dawson has been cast in the
mandalorian season two as ahsoka tano
this is exciting stuff I've only
recently started a truly watch the Clone
Wars because after the way Mandalorian
season 2 ended I was like oh it seems
very essential or I'll probably just get
a lot more from it if I watch the Clone
worse this news comes out and I'm like
I'm so glad I made that decision and
while I'm not finished with the show
I've successfully for a variety of
reasons ahsoka tano is a really great
character I know that in the beat like
way back then when Clone Wars first came
out she actually wasn't that light but I
think as people grew up think like
teenagers grow up they really start to
relate to her identify with her and
she's a very complex character a
multi-layered is in Clone Wars that show
still going on Disney Plus she had a
supporting role in rebels where she did
have a showdown with Anakin Skywalker
like to talk about filling in some gaps
here in rise of Skywalker she is a ghost
voice so I was always assumed that she
probably died somewhere between Return
of the Jedi and the force awakens so she
did have a showdown with Darth Vader she
wasn't involved in the fight against the
Empire necessarily picking up with her
character here in the Mandalorian I feel
like it's really exciting stuff we might
see her story actually conclude in this
show maybe watch how she actually did
meets her ultimate demise or maybe she
just passed away in a really nice
fashion Yoda style or maybe she'll just
show up for one episode and then get
killed up it's really bumpy pull out on
top of all this news the most exciting
thing about it we're finally getting a
live-action version of her people were
really excited when you heard her voice
in rises Skywalker confirming that all
that is canon now it's all linked to the
live-action ones as well we haven't
gotten a live-action version of ahsoka
tano yet now we're finally getting one
the right medium I mean the thrower in a
movie would absolutely be cool but I
think the fact that she started off an
animated series and then transitioning a
character to live-action in a
live-action series just makes the most
sense I am so excited that out of anyone
they got rosario Dawson I think she is
such an underrated actress I think the
first movie that I really saw her in was
Sin City and I just are really paying
attention to her and so many other works
as well I loved her as Claire temple and
the Netflix Marvel shows she's great in
Death Proof she even killed it in a
zombie land double tap she's great at
playing these characters with a lot of
hearts really endearing warm yet an edge
sarcastic wit to them she hasn't gotten
the chance to truly demonstrate how much
of a badass she can be you might play
badass characters where she like holds a
gun or something but if she can play
this character who was a former Jedi
knowing the ahsoka tano personally all
that I know so far is she just she
already seems like perfect casting to me
oh yeah I mean she's yeah like you said
she's got the chops and I feel like at
this stage in her career I think we're
finally getting more of the badass
rosario dawson like with her show that
she's leading the live-action one and
now this and that seems like a perfect
casting choice because she has the right
yeah just quality to her presence that
seems like she could pull off a
character like this super well and also
you know disappear enough into the
makeup that you not that distracted by
her you know yeah that's gonna be a cool
makeup job you see come to life in real
life and maybe as a character starting
point because this takes place just a
little bit after the fall of the empire
a little bit after Return of the Jedi
a Syrian that she what had such a
complex relationship with her Jedi
Master Anakin Skywalker and now that
he's officially passed I'm curious to
see if they'll explore any level of
grievance or weight that that might
carry with her in the show that's
actually all they're gonna do is gonna
be her mourning over Miami with her
lines are about Anakin and it fails the
Bechdel test it would be cool to see her
in mando actually like get into some
nitty-gritty like business yeah I think
something where they both have to hold
their own a little bit and I like get
into some kind of fun I mean you always
want to see some kind of like cool
action with the Mandalorian that seems
like a really cool thing and I hope that
if they do bring her on maybe she can
stick around for more
one episode because in the first season
most of the guest stars seem like they
got you know in episode some of them get
like an episode or two but then they'll
tide it back in together so I imagine
they'll probably do something with her
like that maybe the way how we never
learned what happened with baby Yoda is
gonna be somehow linked to her maybe she
takes it into some hiding I feel like
though
she'll play a significant role I'm
excited for this guys what are your
thoughts on this leave your excitement
down below do you think rosario Dawson
is the perfect casting choice because I
personally do subscribe to the reel
rejects click bells we'll catch you guys
soon